hello everyone I do hope you enjoyed
that game between Fisher and Petrosyan
in 1970 the USSR versus the rest of the
world match but and now it's time to get
back to 1959 candidates and here we have
a game from round 9 again we have Tigran
Petrosian with the white piece against
young Bobby Fischer with the black
pieces and as you enjoy photos so much I
did find that one photo of the two of
them playing in this tournament and as
you can see in this photo they are
younger than in the photos I use for
their profile pictures but I always
tried to get my profile photo to be of
the highest quality possible-- so
sometimes I will use maybe a bit older
photos then the ones than the ones they
looked like at the moment the game was
played and I really enjoyed this photo
of Petrosyan so that's why I most of the
time will use this one and unless he's
like really young or really old but yeah
there's the game you can see petrosyan
with the white piece especially with the
black pieces again I don't know if it's
this exact one or the other one but you
know it's nice to see how things were
set when the game was played so that's
the photo and let's get back to this
game like i said Petrosyan has the white
pieces and we have d4 Fischer plays
Knight to f6 c4 and the E & e6 Saudi
Indian defense Knight to c3 and we have
Bishop to b4 the nimzo-indian we have
III d5 and now Petrosyan goes for a
three and here you generally want to
play Bishop captures on c3 or retreat
with the Bishop to e7
but Fischer goes for the the line Bishop
to d6 which seems a bit more aggressive
but it's it's hard to say probably
Fischer wasn't so well versed in the
openings in those days but you know or
maybe he just wanted to test out if
Petrosyan was really defensively as
strong as they say here we have Knight
to f3 castles and now the immediate c5
Bishop back to e7 and now b4
so now you can see Petrosyan already
created this massive phone chain the
idea being that after this a3 move
one Fischer decided to play Bishop d6 if
you go Bishop to e7 then the same idea
doesn't really apply after night if
three castles after you play see five
you don't really get a chance to put it
before as the black can immediately
counter this with a five but okay in the
game like I said after a 3d six now we
have the immediate c5 Bishop e7 and b4
Fischer plays Knight to e4 and now we
have Bishop to b2 defending the knight
and at any point a move like c6 with a
c6 would definitely be good for black
but Fischer never gets to play it in
this game Knight to d7 I will have
Bishop to d3 with a double attack on the
night and now f5 Knight to e2 preparing
to riemann over the night but also
keeping an eye on the at Foursquare so
Fischer can't really push f4 at any time
Bishop to f6
we have castles by Petrosyan and Queen
to e7
we had Knight to e5 now Fischer captures
Knight captures we have pawn captures
and Bishop to g5 and here we have Bishop
to d4 and this is a very powerful move
by Petrosyan Petrosyan is preparing to
push f3 so he need he needs this bishop
to keep an eye on the e3 pawn as this
report will be undefended when he pushes
f3 but also it prepares a very nice
tactic because now there are two threats
and Fischer can stop both of them here
at Fischer plays Bishop to h6 making
room for the night and g5 because after
f3 is pushed denied it doesn't really
have anywhere to go
we have f3 kicking the night away Knight
to g5 and here comes the second threat
that wasn't very easy I mean it was
impossible to deal with both rate
threats the the trapping of the knight
would have three and also now Pettersson
placed c6 and now you can see you can't
capture the pawn because if you capture
you get Bishop to c5 pinning the Queen
to the rook so after c6 v6 was played
and now b5 and hear Fischer has to think
of something but Petrosyan will always
have an edge his plan is pretty clear if
Fischer doesn't do anything on the Queen
side you'll simply push a four a five
exchange a pawn
control the a file double rooks on the
and you know push his advantage so
Fisher plays a six we have a four pawn
captures pawn captures and patrols in
here exchanges rooks Knight back to f7
and we have Queen to e3 a queen the c3
preparing the other work to come to a
one and then to go all the way to a7 to
attack the weak c7 pawn Queen to h4
Fisher moves the plate to the Kings side
as he will try to create some sort of an
attack rook to a-1 and now we have
Knight to g5 and here
Petrosyan could go for the immediate
rook to a7 but if he does this he won't
get fish or some counter play if he
plays rook to e7 immediately and then
Fischer has this Knight to e4 idea
attacking the Queen also the rook now
moved from a1 so the Queen can come to
e1 and Fischer is also threatening Queen
to f2 so you have to capture it and run
pawn captures now again DF file is open
for the rook Queen to f2 is a threat and
your Bishop is attacked on d3 but again
you can defend night to g3 now after
black captures now you can still gain
advantage with white by playing rock
captures on c7
but again you have to take into account
do you capture them c7 do you capture
this pawn on d3 of course if you capture
on d3 then after rook to e7 black is
perfectly fine and black has enough
compensation which the weak III pawn
white has and the open F file black will
always have many threats
so after this Knight to g5 move
Petrosyan does not want to get Fischer
any chances so first he plays Queen to
e1 he will for he first wants to
exchange Queens and only then push at
the rope to a7 we have Queen to h5
Fisher of course doesn't want to do this
rope to a7 going for the CC c7 pawn and
now Queen to g6 Fischer is trying to do
something and now of course there is the
immediate threat of Knight captures on
f3 as the pawn energy to expend winning
petrol since Queen but Petrosyan of
course doesn't fall for this thing - h1
and now Queen to h5 again an interesting
move because now again if you capture on
c7 now Fischer had the idea of playing
nightcap
an f3 and you can't capture the night
the threat is of course your queen is
attacked Queen captures on h2 checkmate
is a threat so white would have to
defend with Queen to g3 but if you
capture tonight then Queen captures and
you get it's gonna be very hard to play
this King do you want Bishop captures on
e3 with Czech Bishop captures Queen
captures check King f1 Queen h3 King g1
Queen back to e3 check queen blocks and
now Queen captures on d3 and now you
have to calculate a lot of things from
that position when Fisher started this
idea and now you would have to see that
Queen to g3
does give white the advantage because
you're threatening checkmate and g7 and
also threatening to exchange Queens so
after we exchange Queens this would be a
better position for white due to the
past C pawn but again there's no reason
to do this after Queen h5 petrosyan
again doesn't want to get Fischer any
chances so first he pushes f4 and now
the same idea of Knight to f3 it doesn't
really work because the f4 pawn is
blocking the bishop on h6 so there won't
be that Bishop captures on e3 idea
so first try Knight to e4 we have rook
to c7 finally capturing the weak pawn g5
now now Fischer has to go all out
because he you know positionally it's a
lost position for black we have Bishop
to b6 capturing another pawn now
creating 2 passed pawns for white to be
pawn and the C pawn king to h8 we have
Bishop captures pawn captures and now
Bishop to c5 attacking the rook and here
Fischer played rook to g8 and it was in
this position that Bobby Fischer
resigned the game why did you resign
well of course as you can see there are
two very powerful passed pawns White has
and white can it's sufficient to play
something like Bishop to e7 the threat
of course being Bishop to f6 check to
win the game after black blocks this you
still play it and after captures
captures rook to a fate now simply b6
and now the b-pawn wins the game after
we put b7 the bishop is strapped and
that that's pretty much it
even if
you don't do it don't wrap it for some
reason again the two best points will
win the game easily so yeah after that
after that move sorry which move was it
after rook to g8 Bobby Fischer resign in
the game and a wonderful win for team
and petroleum from round 9 of the 1959
candidates tournament and once again as
I didn't show it for a couple of videos
I would like to show you a game from the
final standings as you can see tal won
this tournament with 20 points out of 28
Paul Kerr is the always second for Karis
had second place with 18 and a half
points and then we have Tigran Petrosian
with 15 points 15 and a half
Smith legal each then Bobby Fischer in
sixth place political office on in pal
Benko in last place and if you want to
bring why I'm showing it again well
because it will stick to you I mean one
day or the other you will be maybe in a
bar in a library or somewhere and you
will be able to impress your friends
which are great knowledge of the 1959
candidates tournament so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Tom I played father it's
Michael Sanford Daniel Silverberg
Silverberg and Shuba and Racine for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon probably would another game
from the 1959 candidates tournament
thank you all